And I would say that the square footage of a home and
the number of rooms are both ways of measuring how big the house is.
Of course the square footage is probably going to be a fairly direct measurement
of this, but things like how many bedrooms there are,
what the floor plan is, potentially also other things like the number of
windows can affect how big the house feels from the inside.
So that's why size can be a little bit subjective and
not something that you can probe directly with a single number.
School ranking and neighborhood safety, on the other hand,
I would say, are measurable variables that are associated with the quality of
the neighborhood overall.